so here's why you heard a little bit
about me I teach leadership at Harvard
Business School I had a long business
career and still very actively involved
in running businesses today and when I
go to my hometown Kansas City or when I
go back to New York City and I tell
people that I'm teaching and I'm a
professor at Harvard Business School
they are really they're impressed they
say wow that is really great I would
have thought that you would be doing
that and so I feel really good and then
they say uh what do you teach and I say
I teach leadership and then they go oh
and I go and I've gotten used to this
why what's the problem why oh well first
of all they say can you teach leadership
and they say what is that
and and then they'll say don't you have
to I think that's the kind of thing
you're either born a leader or you're
not but I don't say you can teach that
in the class and give me in two minutes
what you teach and I think oh my god
this is this is so depressing and what
I've learned from all these experiences
is actually no one knows exactly what
leadership is if I did a poll in this
audience and asked each of you to write
down right now your definition of what a
leader does I've learned from experience
I would get a hundred different
definitions some of you would say it's
about getting people to follow you some
of you would say it's about being a good
follower some of you would say to me
forget all that stuff are you making
money or you're not making money if
you're making money you're good leader
and I've realized and I've spent the
last six or seven years trying to
demystify leadership because I realized
the lack of clarity on what it is is a
big problem because all of us get to the
point in our careers where we're going
to be a leader we're going to be
President on stage we're going to be
mayor we're going to
CEO of a company we're going to run a
division and we don't know we're
supposed to do because no one agrees
what a leader even does okay
so what I'm going to try to do in the
next few minutes is break it down and
give you a few things to think about in
terms of being a leader so let me start
and yes if you're expecting something
high-tech from Harvard I hate to break
the news to you you ain't going to see
it let me talk about my definition of
leadership leadership in its core
involves three basic things number one
can you figure out what you believe this
is not an easy thing to do the
television is full of pundits and other
people or you go to cocktail receptions
everybody is really good at telling you
or a public official why they don't like
what they did this that's not leadership
though leadership is you're in charge
you're the owner what do you believe
what do you think should be done and the
truth is most of us know who are
striving to be leaders we don't know
most of the time when I get in a
business situation I'm not sure I
haven't figured it out yet I'm still
thinking about it
but what a leader does and what
distinguishes a leader a leader is
striving always to figure out as if
you're the owner what do you believe so
that's step one step two once you have
conviction about what you believe a
leader has got the ability to act in an
appropriate way
on those beliefs how many meetings have
I been in over my life where I made a
decision or we made a decision where I
thought we made a decision we implement
it got all screwed up and I got somebody
comes up to me very proudly and says I
never agreed with that I knew I knew
that was a mistake and after I'm done
trying to strangle them to death I'll
say where were you you were in all the
meetings well I don't want to speak up
and I want to make waves you seem very
sure bull what a leader does is have the
guts and the ability
to act and sometimes if you're a leader
acting may not mean it's pretty
complicated you may have to think out a
very detailed action plan for how to act
but what a leader does is learns to act
third part whatever the action is it
needs to add value to someone else
ideally your organization customer
client society someone else so by this
definition can you figure out what you
believe do you have the ability to act
on it in a way that adds value by this
definition you actually don't need to
manage anybody to be a leader you can be
a leader without managing anybody and
there's millions of leaders in this
world by the same token you could manage
tens of thousands of people and I deal
with a lot of people who do who are not
good leaders at all might be decent
managers that they aren't leaders and
what we often criticize public officials
company officials you name it because of
this they don't actually they try to
figure out what everybody else thinks
they should do but they don't actually
get conviction on what they believe
that's a different thing
that's what a leader does or they have
conviction but they're afraid to act
because of the ramifications made it's
unpopular in a way that adds value and
by the way when industries get in
trouble they stop adding value so that's
my definition and I would ask you how do
you stack up here this is what a leader
strives to do now why do people fail
then to be leaders and I'm constantly
harvard's a little bit I've learned like
Switzerland by the time they get to me
they're really desperate okay
I mean they've tried everything and then
someone has referred them to me and it's
usually a CEO or somebody well-known and
here the biggest reasons and they're not
the reasons that I always thought
reasons people get in trouble is are you
willing to ask a question a lot of
people because they don't know what a
leader does they think a leader has to
have all the answers
you know we've even had public officials
who say I need to have the
sirs I can't admit that I was wrong
we've heard we've heard other things
that suggest they're not willing to ask
questions as a leader leadership is
about asking the right questions there
are absolutely times where you've got to
say we're going to do this but a leader
is confident enough to know you have to
ask questions and you'd be shocked how
many leaders disagree we're promising
leaders disagree with that they think oh
I can't do that I'm going to look weak
I'm going to people gonna lose respect
for me and what they learn is people
will lose respect for you because if
they think you don't know what the heck
is going on if you never ask a question
you're not second what relates to not
asking a question isolation inability to
learn why do you leaders fail isolation
you never ask a question everyone around
you has got feedback and you sent out a
vibe I don't want to hear it and you're
not able to learn and this is why you
see all sorts of people move up move up
move up fizzle out fail they can't adapt
they can't learn to ask a question or
you see people going from one venue to a
different context and they never learn
they have to relearn and ask a whole
series of questions going from business
to government is a great example you've
got to ask a whole series of questions
and go to school again and a lot of
leaders think I can't do that look like
a weakling I look like I don't know what
I'm doing what they don't understand is
a confident leader actually ask
questions with an open mind the other
big reason why this gets people in
trouble business going well it's going
well it's going well and then things
change they always do sadly which is
what makes business so hard and you're
isolated and you're stuck doing things
the way you've always done them because
you've been a success because you did it
this way are you open to asking a
question and actually listening and
being open minded about changing your
mind most liberating words and business
are I don't know I was wrong I'm not
sure maybe we need to rethink this can
you do it
and then last in order to do those
things it makes some people feel
vulnerable yeah if you're asking for
advice you're asking a question for
some people makes them very
uncomfortable can you stand it can you
be yourself or do you think you need to
have all the answers if you're somebody
who does my experience is you're going
to run out of steam at some point
world's to complicated's changing too
fast you will not reach your potential
okay so last two points there are two
and I'm simplifying this down given the
time there are two processes going on at
all times whether you think of it this
way or not in terms of basis of
questions you should be asking
I'll start the first one which is more
your brain vision priorities and
alignment what I mean by vision that's
used a lot but here's what I mean by it
how do you add value to someone else to
a customer or client based on what key
competency ie what's our edge what's
different about us excellent leaders are
asking this question all the time I came
from an industry where the only way to
survive was to ask this all the time
products are getting commoditized all
the time regulation other changes
globalization technological innovation
all sorts of things are making it what
added value three years ago doesn't work
anymore ask people in the bookstore
industry or many many others anybody who
has had to compete with Apple or Amazon
this question is in the extreme you've
got to ask it all the time leader has to
ask this question has to strive how do
we add value based on what clear
competencies then you have to establish
three to five key priorities to add that
value and build those competencies and
we're doing this quickly and then the
rest of your life is alignment we have
the right people are we giving them
right tasks or we pay the way we pay
people the way we problem even the way
we sit is it aligned with how we add
value this is critical for a leader and
when I see a leader that's in trouble or
business is in trouble and many of them
been successful for a long time they
don't know what happened it usually
starts with this they are afraid to ask
a question and this is the question they
fail to ask given all the changes in the
world how do we add value are we still
adding value based on what
he competencies and then are we willing
to realign the business to do that this
is a series of questions and this is
processes going on there's another more
disturbing process that's going on in
parallel and this is disturbing and the
subject of this second process is
terrifying disturbing unnerving and the
second process is about you this is a
rough one you have to continue to
understand yourself better to do all
this stuff why can't you ask a question
why can't you delegate why can't you
change your practices why can't you be
open mind when you see a freight train
coming right at you and you convince
yourself it's not real why can't you
share power why can't you do all the
things that you do why do you lose your
temper when you're confronted why why
why why why why why and we could talk
for hours what a leader has to
constantly do particularly as you get
more senior in the stakes get higher you
have to understand yourself better last
comment which I guess gets the topic of
what we're supposed to be here talking
about which is mentoring and coaching
you cannot do this alone
first of all leadership is a team sport
you want to build anything of
significance you need to engage others
everybody would on the surface of it
agree with that but one of the things
that you've got to do in order to
understand whether you're on the right
track is you've got to be willing to
tell people what's on your mind share
information self disclose I call it and
seek advice and I can't tell you how
many leaders say to me you must be crazy
I can't do that that is terrible advice
a leader doesn't do that that's going to
bring me down that's going to make me my
people are going to think I go from here
I can't tell you every week we have
executives come and they say that's
going to take me from here to here and
what I say to them your people are their
biggest fear and they are freaking out
they're not freaking out that you're
asking too many questions they're
freaking out that you're not asking any
questions and they're afraid that
everybody knows and everybody in the
company knows you're out of alignment
ever
buddy but you okay so let me mention
here's a here's the reason though people
despite the green wholeheartedly with
this concept don't still don't get
feedback and get isolated and failed to
learn there's two types of relationships
to get advice one I would call mentoring
second is coaching we use and we talk
about them like they're the same they
are not not even close a mentor
mentoring means I tell you a story you
give me advice based on the story the
problem is the advice is only as good as
my story and every one of us especially
if we're successful has blind spots okay
and if you play sport golf tennis
something like that imagine getting on
the phone with your golf coach and
saying let me describe my swing I left
my left arm straight I had an athletic
stance I turned like this they saw
sounds great here's the praat you would
never do that sounds ridiculous right
coaching requires direct observation
okay you need to have coaching
relationships a mentoring relationship
isn't enough who observes you the people
that observe you every day if I ask them
your strengths and weaknesses and where
the company's in trouble it would not
even take them ten seconds to answer
they'd know immediately sometimes the
last person to know there's a problem is
you and so you've got to be better at
reaching out to people who observe you
every day and seeking advice and
disclosing what's on your mind and for
many people this is very uncomfortable
and second your people especially if
you're a senior person do not want to
tell you okay unless they're suicidal or
want to blow themselves up nobody wants
to tell you but I can assure you they
know they've got the answers you must
ask there's an enormous power asymmetry
between a leader and a subordinate only
you can turn the key and most often when
I sit with somebody who's worked with me
over the years and I'll ask him can you
give me one action that I need to
improve
on one thing we need to do differently
normally their answer is nothing I can
think of and I sit there and I say now
I'm serious I want to just take a minute
I want you to think of one thing beads
of sweat forming on their forehead and
they're saying this is some kind of
weird loyalty test and this has got a
sick trick and their debate and you sit
there and you're earnestly saying no I'm
really serious I really mean it and
you've got to be very patient it's got
to be done one on one they eventually
will say something they will regret it
as soon as it comes out of their mouth
you'll hear it it's devastating
it's devastating because you realize oh
my god it's true
they won't you'll thank them they will
leave you will call home and you say am
i and they'll say yeah that does sound
like you and your oh my god you got a
problem but you will improve you will
improve and you will work on it and
people in your company will know to lit
that when you ask a question they mean
that they will come and be more likely
to give you advice you will be less
isolated and you will do better at all
these things so again what is leadership
can you figure out what you believe you
have the guts and the ability to act on
it in a way that adds value are you
willing to ask a question and part of my
role in life as a professor is to say to
people it's okay I'm not a touchy-feely
person I didn't certainly didn't come
from a touchy-feely industry it's okay
to ask a question be somewhat vulnerable
but you've got to have coaching
relationships as well as mentoring share
information and seek advice good to talk
to you
you